Well, the weirder getting weirder, though. Donald
Trump said in Scotland that he was leaving early
in order to go to the Eugene Carroll rape
trial in New York, apparently to testify,
which was news to so many people. Wow,
Trump's leaving, he's going to testify,
and then he just didn't. And his lawyer said he's
not testifying. What are you talking about? This
just goes from the comical to the completely
absurd to the pathetic and dishonest. Here is
Donald Trump. Trump had until 5:00 pm yesterday
to let the court know in writing if he was going
to testify today and he told I believe this
was Irish press. I don't know if this video
was filmed in Ireland or in Scotland. Here is
Trump saying how terrible it is. He's got to
leave early. He could be playing golf. You know,
he's got to leave early and go testify, I guess,
in the rape trial that's happening
in New York. Take a look at this.
Oh, boy. Our video is glitching badly.
That's not good. Let's see. Let's take.
Here we go. Be violent and have to leave
Scotland. Wherever great property is,
have to leave early. I don't have to,
but I choose to. Will you attend the
trial? Mr. President, it's a disgrace that it's
allowed to happen. But false accusations against
a rich guy, or in my case, against a famous,
rich and political person that's leading the
polls by 40 points. Right. And I have to go back
for a woman that made a false accusation about
me and I have a judge is extremely hostile.
And I'm going to go back and I'm going to
confront this. But this woman is a disgrace and
it shouldn't be allowed to happen in my country.
All right. So he very clearly says, I'm going to
go back and I'm going to confront the woman and
I'm going to go to the trial. Okay. Well, he
had up until yesterday at 5:00 to notify the
court that he's going to do that. And of course,
he's not going to. NBC News. Trump won't testify
in Jean Carroll. Rape and Defamation Trial After
judge's deadline passes, Judge Lewis Kaplan set a
deadline of 5 p.m. Sunday for Trump to notify the
court if he wanted to testify after his lawyers
said that he would not. So what do we make of
it? We don't know. Did Trump think he was going
to go testify? Did Trump think the media would
be impressed by him saying he was going to go?
His attorneys did not issue a filing by
the 5 p.m. Sunday deadline that was set.
Closing arguments started earlier this morning.
Lawyers for Trump and Carol rested their case
in the civil trial last week. Caplan
left open the possibility for Trump,
who said he would not appear to take the witness
stand, giving him time to change his mind. Trump's
lawyer said last week Trump will not testify. They
are not putting on any witnesses. His attorney,
Joe Tacopina, reiterated that on Thursday when
he rested. He told the judge he spoke to Trump
earlier and Trump waived his right to testify.
Trump, however, told reporters on a golf course
in Ireland he was going back to New York because
of the case. I'll probably attend. She's a fake.
It's a disgrace. I've got to go back and do it.
So, listen, I have absolutely no idea where this
case is going to go. We're going to look at
deposition testimony from Trump in a in a
couple of minutes. I have no idea what this court
will find on any of these questions. It has been.
Obfuscation and chaos and wacky depositions
it's been. There's no sensible way
for me to come up with a prediction, and we'll
kind of have our answer soon. So. So we'll figure
that out. Even legal opinions that I've looked
at are sort of split as to what is to be expected
here, What we can be sure of, what we can be
sure of is that no matter the outcome, Trump
will claim either victory or will martyr himself
that no matter what that we know is going to
happen. Why did Trump say he was going to testify
when he wasn't? We don't know. Let's now look at
what when Trump did testify in the sense of being
deposed. Insane videos released over the weekend.